when it comes to distributed systems
handling failure is key kubernetes helps
with this by utilizing controllers that
can watch the state of your system and
then restart services that stop
performing but on the other hand
kubernetes can actually forcibly
terminate your applications to ensure
the overall health of the system in this
episode of kubernetes best practices
let's take a look at how you can help
kubernetes do its job more efficiently
and reduce a dime time your apps
experience
[Music]
in the pre container world most
applications are running on VMs or
physical machines if an application
crashed they could take quite a while to
boot up a replacement to take its place
or even worse someone would need to log
into the machine and fix the issue by
hand even in the middle of the night if
you only have one or two machines to run
the application this time to recovery
was unacceptable
so instead it became common to use
process level monitoring to restart
applications when they would crash if
the application crashed the monitoring
process could capture the exit code and
then restart the server instantly with
the advent of systems like kubernetes
this kind of system was just built into
the infrastructure itself kubernetes
uses an invent to make sure that
resources are healthy from containers to
the notes themselves this means you no
longer need to manually run these
monitoring processes if a resources
fails a health check kubernetes will
just automatically spin up a replacement
but kubernetes does a lot more than
monetary application for crashes you
know it can create more copies of your
application to run on multiple machines
it can update your application you know
it can even run multiple versions of
your application at the same time so
this means that there are many reasons
why kubernetes might terminate a
perfectly healthy container like if you
update your deployment with a rolling
update kubernetes will slowly terminate
old pods while spitting up new ones if
you drain a node kubernetes will
terminate all pods in that node and you
know if node runs out of resources
kubernetes will terminate pods to free
those resources so it's important that
your application can handle termination
gracefully so that if there's a minimal
impact on the end user and as a minimal
impact on the time to recovery so this
means that you know it should save all
the data that needs to be saved
close down any network connections
finish any work that's left you know
other similar tasks so in practice this
means your application needs to handle
the sig term message when it receives
this message it should begin to shut
down once kubernetes decided to
terminate your pod a series of events
takes place let's look at
one of these steps in the kubernetes
termination lifecycle so let's say we're
about to terminate one of these pots at
this point the pod will stop getting new
traffic containers running in the pod
will not be affected but all new traffic
will be prevented from coming in so now
let's look at the pre stop hook the pre
stop hook is a special command or HTTP
request that is sent to the containers
in the pot if your application doesn't
gracefully shut down when receiving a
sick term you can use this hook to
trigger a graceful shutdown so most
programs gracefully shut down when
receiving a sick term but if you're
using a third party code or some system
that you don't really have control over
the pre stop hook is a great way to
trigger a graceful shutdown without
modifying the application so now at this
point kubernetes will send the sick time
signal to the containers in the pot this
signal lets the containers note that are
going to be shut down soon so your code
should listen for this event and then
start shutting down cleanly at this
point so this may include stopping any
long live connections like a database
connection or a WebSocket stream saving
the current state and doing things like
that so even if you're using the pre
stop hook it's important that you test
what happens to your application when
you send it the stick term signal so
you're not surprised when it happens in
production at this point kubernetes will
wait for a specified time call the
termination grace period by default this
is 30 seconds it's important to note
that this happens in parallel the pre
stop hook and the sick term signal so
kubernetes will not wait for the pre
stop hook or the sick term signal to
finish if your app finishes shutting
down before the termination grace period
is done kubernetes will just move the
next step immediately now if your pod
takes longer than 30 seconds shut down
make sure you increase the grace period
you can do that by setting the
termination grace period seconds option
in the pod llamo for example this
example has it set at 60 seconds and now
the last step if the containers are
still running after the grace period
they are sent the cig kill signal and
then forcibly removed at this point
kubernetes cleans up all the objects as
well
kubernetes terminates pods for many
reasons and making sure that your
application handles these terminations
gracefully is core to creating a stable
service I'll see you on the next episode
of kubernetes best practices
[Music]